As Castro has said,
as long as the concept of sovereignty exists as the of independent nations
and peoples and as the right of all peoples,
we will not accept the exclusion of our people from that right.
However,
the United States sought to establish a new arbitrary and illegal,
that of violating the airspace of any small country.
We want to build socialism.
We have declared ourselves partisans of those fighting for peace.
We have declared ourselves within the group of non-aligned countries,
despite being Marxist-Leninists,
because the non-aligned,
like us,
fight against.
We want peace.
It is at a new disposal in a continent of America.
It is embodied and summarized in the cry that day by day our
masses proclaim as an irrefutable expression of their decision to fight,
paralyzing the invader's armed hand.
That proclamation is confirmation or death.